an expansive new era of private
enterprise may be dawning among the
ancient rooftops of Old Havana but for
Michael Connors that was one party oh
it's another ordinary but entertaining
day at the office these are the mail
drops and you would just put your letter
in there Connors has been leading his
fellow Americans around this world
heritage site for 15 years this is the
hotel that Jimmy Carter stayed in
sharing his love of Cuban culture
undulating baroque line and his
fascination with this capital city's
unique architecture ball roll or a roll
call call neoclassicism Connors helps
organize high-priced package tours for
visitors and on this trip they include
his cousin Matt and this is an
incredibly warm and gracious people and
yeah there's a lot of bureaucracy and
there's a lot of history between the two
countries but we have so much more in
common to appreciate that common ground
many of the hundred thousand Americans
who visited Cuba last year required a
travel license from the US government
how tricky in terms of bureaucracy is it
to get the license to visit here it is
tricky it is as we say in Cuba ace muy
complicado we apply every year for this
license to take people to Cuba for
educational humanitarian cultural
people-to-people exchange and while
these costly cultural tools constitute
tourism in everything but name the
recent relaxation of US travel
restrictions may mean many more
mass-market American tourists will
arrive
Cuba's best beaches have long attracted
visitors from Europe and while the
arrival of Americans on these shores
could present a business opportunity it
could also mean a real challenge to the
islands tourism infrastructure
more than 10 charter flights leave US
airports for Cuba each day but major
carriers like United Airlines are also
contemplating routes to the island how
do you think the Cuban government is
going to cope with the challenge if
there is a huge influx of tourists here
I have no idea because they're having a
hard time working with the people that
are coming now
3 million global visitors contributed 2
billion dollars the Cuban economy last
year making it the state's second
largest source of foreign revenue but as
family-run guest houses and cafes
attract clients away from state-owned
hotels and restaurants it's the private
sector that has the most to gain and
that's thanks in part to a new US policy
which encourages entrepreneurship in
this communist country